[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIGEL SYLVESTER: The world
from beyond my handlebars
is such a unique position.
It moves faster.
It's more intense.
I'm forced to think faster.
I feel more comfortable riding
my bike sometimes than walking.
LAURA LING: When I watch you
ride, I am just transfixed.
How did you get into BMX?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: Like most
kids in my neighborhood,
just riding bicycles
around was the thing to do.
It was a natural thing for us.
It was fun.
It was a way to get to
where ever we wanted to go.
And it was that first point of
like, I felt freedom from home.
And a lot of years
passed in between
until I finally seen BMX riding
for the first time on TV.
And that's what really
changed everything for me.
And once I seen that,
I was like, wow,
this is what I really
want to do in my life.
Because of my neighborhood
and because of my environment,
riding BMX on a
professional level
and dreaming to be a
professional BMX rider
wasn't common.
People would sometimes
call me a white boy
because they didn't
understand the sport
and because they
associated BMX riding
with only young white
men from middle America
or places like that.
But it was something that
I had for a very long.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm a kid from Queens.
And I would have never
imagined in a million years
that I would have
the opportunity
to ride my bicycle
around the world.
It's incredible.
LAURA LING: Did you get pressure
at home from your family
to follow that traditional
route and go to school
and get a good job?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: Of course.
My family, my mom and
dad, came to America
to pursue better opportunities.
It was very rigid growing
up, which was fine.
It taught me a lot of
valuable life lessons
that I would later
carry on into my career.
LAURA LING: Like what?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: Hard work.
I learned hard
work and dedication
and sacrifice at
home from my family.
And those are things that
I use every single day.
It's like, how much are
you willing to sacrifice?
How hard are you willing
to work to go achieve
your goals and your dreams?
LAURA LING: How
hard do you work?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: I
work every single day.
Anyone that knows me knows that
I'm thinking about bike riding,
I'm thinking about a project
every single second of the day.
And when it comes to
the actual bike riding,
sometimes it may take
one try to land a trick.
Other times, it
may take one day.
It make take a week.
It may be something you
have to leave and come
back and try again.
LAURA LING: You're not just
a professional BMX rider.
You really are a BMX
artist and filmmaker.
You make these really
incredible videos
riding around different cities.
What are you trying to
accomplish through your videos?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: For me, it's
about sharing my point of view
with the world.
Not many people can get on a
bike and go blast on a bridge
or bomb a hill in SF or blast
through Shibuya Crossing.
I want to share
that with people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For me, I never really
embraced riding contests.
It's always been about content.
I just want to deliver
people an amazing experience.
I want them to watch my
videos and just be in awe
and be amazed and learn
something and be inspired.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Would you
say that BMX riding
is THE ritual of your life?
NIGEL SYLVESTER: It's something
I do almost every single day.
And if I'm not doing it,
I'm thinking about it.
You know, it's always
around me, all the time.
It's one of those
conflicts in my life.
The feeling of landing a
trick is like nothing else
and it never gets old.
It's such an adrenaline rush.
It's such a feeling of
a self-accomplishment.
It's more than just
doing a bike trick.
It's about making it look good,
about making it beautiful.
The majority of
people in your life
have ridden a bicycle before.
They know the feeling.
They know that feeling
of cruising down a block
and how joyful that is,
that level of independence.
Once you find that sweet
spot and you find it
all on your own, you're
able to just soar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Click here to see
Nigel blast through Shibuya
Crossing, dodge flying fish
at Tokyo's famous fish market,
and brace to get sumo-ed in
his latest episode of "Go."